what's up 2017 we're going to try hey
Internet is your favorite tool that's
good so yeah we're gonna try out some
items that came out in 2017 I'm a little
skeptical about these newfangled backs
food I'm like a classic
Taco Bell we're here to talk about you
have the blue raspberry fries that makes
sense
oh man fries ah I'm getting worse rate
raises are crazy crazy it works it's a
it this would complement a taco supreme
well oh yeah I'm 5 out of 10 I might get
it I would do a 4 out of 10 but if it
was that particular day in the summer
time and I'm shredding with my friends I
might be daring to get this we're gonna
truck the ribeye Havarti burger
jack-in-the-box which we're only a 1 I
didn't bring any like nicer scissors I
think we're gonna ask him to cut it I
think that's a bad idea boy is there is
there any way you can cut that in half
thank you and do you have a jumping jack
splash it's very moist looking red wine
glaze cheers Cheers
[Music]
primo you know what everybody's at a
restaurant a burger that it feels like
you're drinking wanna try some of this
jumping jack flash you know I do see
what this is about this is just like
Hawaiian Punch it tastes like the like
those darryl drinks pretty good all
right off to Burger King for some
milkshakes to wash down that Burger
Cinnamon Toast Crunch milkshake and
flaming hot mac and Cheetos all right
thank you
this looks crazy it looks like an alien
what oh really dry maybe in the the lab
they had a good version for some we're
into mass production it I don't know
where the melty cheese was there's hope
in there's a cinnamon toast crunch mom
take what he wants
I'll try the lucky charm my old man wow
that really does taste like a good
breakfast replacement Thanks all right
you did right with a milkshakes burger
milkshakes eight out of ten the shakes
for good shake were pretty dope shake
for great those Cheetos and give it a
zero out of ten
[Laughter]
do you still have the grand mac you have
any new items they don't have the Grand
Mac anymore 2017 sucks so we're gonna
make our own grand Mac out of two Big
Macs I love Big Macs I was really
excited about the Grand Mac still life
still live all right no Grand Mac what
we did it
we tried it's right next time it only
the lesson is that you just gotta go for
it when you see it when it's one when
it's there do it do it now live your
life cut to a slow motion of me eating
that Big Mac but all in all this stuff
we did I was pretty good yeah 2017 2017
no more double super cute boot flew no
more without something everybody go to
poop